well what i want to do is make sure
people are supported from day one that's
why i'd have a temporary moratorium on
the green energy levy to save people
money from their fuel bills and what i
will also do is reverse the national
insurance rise to make sure people are
keeping more of their own money what's
vitally important at this moment is we
get economic growth going and at the
moment we've got the highest taxes for
70 years that's why i believe in lower
taxes to get growth going to encourage
businesses to invest and that way
there'll be more money in people's
pockets
critics say those sort of schemes won't
scratch the surface in terms of the
thousands of pounds people will need to
help them struggling with rising energy
bills why are you ruling out direct
financial support for people struggling
to deal with the cost of living well
what i'm promising is from day one
people will have lower taxes they'll
also have lower energy bills because i'm
going to put a temporary moratorium on
the green energy levy but what we need
is we need a growing economy and a
growing economy will be mean more money
in people's pockets but what it will
also mean
is thriving businesses higher wages
higher productivity and the problem
we've had for decades in this country is
low growth which has squeezed the
funding available for public services
with respect those policies are going to
provide people with a few hundred pounds
extra people are expecting their energy
bills to go up by perhaps as much as 2
000 pounds
why are you ruling out direct financial
support to help people struggling with
the cost of living
what i'm talking about is enabling
people to keep more money in their own
pockets what i don't believe in is
taxing people to the highest level in 70
years and then giving them their own
money back
we are conservatives we believe in low
taxes and what i'm not going to do is
announce the next budget
in advance of course we'll need to deal
with the circumstances
as they arise but my fundamental
principle
is that people should keep more of their
own money and we should be on the side
of people who do the right thing people
who go out to work people who set up
their own businesses
people who are contributing to the
economy because we need economic growth
to get through these difficult times at
present there's a recession predicted
and i don't need to tell people what a
recession is like it would mean people
losing their jobs it would mean hardship
we need to avoid that by growing our
economy okay
i'm sorry to repeat this but i mean this
is this is really important and people
are really worried about their energy
bills
this winter and the projections that
they're going to rise by thousands of
pounds what you're proposing will only
help people by a few hundred pounds why
are you ruling out
direct financial support to help people
struggling with the cost of living well
what i'm doing is making sure people are
paying less taxes and also having a
temporary moratorium on the green energy
levy to save people money on their fuel
bills i'm not going to write the budget
in advance we'll see what the situation
is like
in the autumn but i'm committed to
making sure people are supported and i'm
committed to growing the economy why are
you running out direct financial support
what we can't have i'm not i'm not going
to comment on exactly what's going to be
in the budget what i've been clear about
you are ruling out
what i am clear about
is that from day one
i will reduce taxes and i'll also have a
temporary moratorium on the green energy
levy to save people money on their fuel
bills and what's important
is that we get the economy growing we
can't get the economy growing if we have
the highest tax rates for 70 years in
this country and i'm determined to
change that i'm determined to challenge
the orthodoxy and i'm determined to do
things differently but i'm not going to
write the budget in advance why do some
of your own colleagues say that your tax
cutting budget that you're proposing
amounts to an electoral suicide note
well i'm running a positive campaign
and my campaign is all about growing the
british economy i know that we have huge
talent around this country i want to get
rid of those eu laws off our statute
books i want to drive investment and
growth across the economy and i want to
do it by allowing people to keep more of
their own money and making it easier to
set up businesses that's the way we're
going to drive success in this country
so you're not worried about dominique
wrong's comments that your emergency
budget amounts to an electoral suicide
what i care about
is britain being successful i don't
agree with these poor tents of doom i
don't agree agree with this decliners
talk i believe our country's best days
are ahead of us and what i'm going to do
if selected as prime minister is keep
taxes low get the economy growing
unleash the potential right across
britain that's what i'm about just one
final question if i may your opponent
rishi sinak says he will scrap a
proposed reception center for asylum
seekers before they head to rwanda in
linton on ooze in north yorkshire the
villagers there say they don't want this
reception center which is soon access he
doesn't want it what would you do about
it
well my understanding from the defense
secretary is that site is not going
ahead so it's a moot point because it
won't be going forward
mistrust thank you very much thank you